freiburg im breisgau mit seinem
wahrzeichen dem münster ein guter
ausgangspunkt für eine tour durch den
schwarzwald bekannt ist die
studentenstadt auch für ihre
wasserrinnen die sogenannten bächle die
die altstadt durchfließen michael gilles
hat hier germanistik studiert das ist
einfach eine vielseitige landschaft ist
man kann wandern fahrradfahren
das wetter ist meistens toll hier im
süden und man kann abends draußen in den
cafés sitzen gemütlich was trinken das
wetter genießen was machst du schön
nicht weit von freiburg liegt das
glottertal für einige besucher der
inbegriff der region schwarzwald das
klinikgebäude carlsbau es bot die
kulisse für die fernsehserie die
schwarzwaldklinik von 1985 bis 1989
schalteten allein in deutschland jede
woche um die 25 millionen zuschauer ein
die 70 folgen um chefarzt professor
brinkmann und sein team wurden in 38
länder exportiert von ungarn bis nach
südafrika
die zeiten in denen fans der arztserie
das glottertal geradezu überrannten sind
vorbei das café schill erinnert
weiterhin an die dreharbeiten und die
schauspieler fritz schill wurde durch
die serie vom friseur zum
souvenirverkäufer wir hatten sehr sehr
gute jahre
was in der zwischenzeit natürlich die
normalität jetzt erreicht hat aber heute
noch leben wir von den leuten die
deswegen noch zu dieser klinik bildern
südöstlich des lautertals liegt der ttc
ein beliebter badeseen der wettergott
verwöhnt den schwarzwald oft mit vielen
schönen sonnenstunden
deshalb kann man einen der zahlreichen
seen auch wunderbar baden gehen gerade
familien urlauber schätzen den fast 40
meter tiefen badesee einen von rund 30
im schwarzwald
der schwarzwald hatte schon im
mittelalter seinen namen da er so tannen
und fichten reich ist der holz reichtum
spiegelt sich auch in den heimischen
produkten wieder am bekanntesten
die kuckucksuhr bereits 1730 soll es die
ersten kuckucksuhren gegeben haben
die firma rombach und hass in schonach
produziert sie seit mehr als 100 jahren
angefangen mit dieser variante man in
der schilder handbemalt als das ist der
ursprüngliche kuckucksuhren typ und wir
jetzt unsere firma hat vor sieben jahren
eine weitere variante ins leben rufen
nämlich montag
also wir machen jetzt auch hochmoderne
kuckucksuhren
und die schlagen an diese uhr ist 50
fach vergrößert als sie 1980 erbaut
wurde war sie die größte kuckucksuhr der
welt
auch der typische schwarzwald hut mit
den 14 roten bullen ist in schonach
größer als normalerweise
nebenan in triberg stürzen die
vielleicht bekanntesten wasserfälle
deutschland mehr als 160 meter in die
tiefe
im süden des schwarzwald der feldberg
mit rund 1500 metern der höchste berg
der region fasziniert mich die gute luft
hier jetzt das schöne wetter die
landschaft einfach mich begeistert die
natur man kann wandern radfahren es
bietet einfach sehr viele möglichkeiten
vom aussichtsturm reicht der blick bis
zu den alpen zurück in freiburg michael
gira arbeitet abends in einer der
zahlreichen kneipen ein idealer ort
einen sommertag im schwarzwald
ausklingen zu lassen